DIRE.
THE PRIME MINISTER SAYS THOSE
WHO VIOLATE CONTROL MEASURES
WILL FACE STERN CONSEQUENCES.
>>> HUMANITARIAN AGENCIES ARE
SOUNDING ALARM OVER THE RISE OF
MASS KIDNAPPINGS, TARGETING
SCHOOL CHILDREN IN NIGERIA.
THE LATEST HAPPENED JUST DAYS
AGO.
THE U.N. ESTIMATES NEARLY A
THOUSAND STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
ABDUCTED SINCE DECEMBER.
MOST OF THE KIDNAPPINGS ARE
TAKING PLACE IN THE COUNTRY'S
NORTHERN REGION, WITH KADUNA
STATE HARDEST HIT.
KIDNAP FOR RANSOM IS QUICK
BECOMING A THRIVING INDUSTRY IN
NIGERIA, ONE THAT HAS GROWN
SIGNIFICANTLY SINCE 2014 WHEN
BOKO HARAM INSURGENTS KIDNAPPED
300 SCHOOL CHILDREN IN CHIBOK.
SINCE THEN MORE THAN 600 SCHOOLS
HAVE BEEN CLOSED BECAUSE OF
SAFETY CONCERNS AND THE COVID-19
PANDEMIC HAS ONLY MADE IT WORSE.
GIRLS ACCOUNT FOR MOST OF THE
CHILDREN WHO ARE NOT ATTENDING
SCHOOL AND HAVE THE MOST TO
LOSE.
TIME NOW FOR THE EXCHANGE WHERE
WE LOOK AT WHY KEEPING GIRLS IN
SCHOOL BENEFITS EVERYONE.
OUR NEXT GUEST WAS ALMOST KILLED
BY THE PAKISTANI TALIBAN FOR
SUPPORTING A GIRLS RIGHT TO
LEARN.
IN PART 2 OF A WIDE-RANGING
INTERVIEW WITH ZAIN ASHER, SPOKE
TO MALALA YOUSAFZAI ABOUT WHY
EDUCATING GIRLS IS SUCH A
CRITICAL ISSUE.
>> SO WE'VE TALKED A LOT ON THIS
SHOW ABOUT WOMEN AND GIRLS
WEATHERING THE STORM OF THIS
PANDEMIC.
AND WE'VE HAD A LOT OF EXPERTS
ON THE SHOW, PEOPLE FROM THINK
TANKS.
YOU ARE IN A REAL UNIQUE
POSITION BECAUSE YOU HAVE
EXPERIENCED SIMILAR PLIGHTS,
SIMILAR TRIALS AS THE VERY
PEOPLE YOU ARE TRYING TO HELP.
YOU HAVE EXPERIENCED THE VERY
WORST, THE VERY WORST OF
GENDER-BASED VIOLENCE.
WHAT DO YOU WANT THE WORLD TO
KNOW ABOUT WHAT WOMEN AND GIRLS
ARE GOING THROUGH BECAUSE OF
THIS PANDEMIC?
>> GIRLS EDUCATION HAS BEEN A
KEY CAUSE THAT I AM FIGHTING
FOR.
AND I WAS ONE OF THOSE GIRLS WHO
COULD NOT GO TO SCHOOL WHEN I
WAS ONLY 11 YEARS OLD.
SO I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR A GIRL TO BE IN SCHOOL.
FOR HER PROTECTION, FOR HER
SAFETY BUT ALSO FOR HER FUTURE.
FOR HER INDEPENDENCE.
AND I HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR IT
BECAUSE THERE ARE 130 MILLION
GIRLS WHO ARE OUT OF SCHOOL
RIGHT NOW.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
CREATE A WORLD WHERE EVERY GIRL
HAS ACCESS TO SAFE AND QUALITY
EDUCATION.
BECAUSE OF THIS PANDEMIC --.
AND ESTIMATED THAT THERE IS A
RISK THAT 20 MILLION MORE GIRLS
COULD LOSE THEIR EDUCATION
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOW LIMITED TO
THEIR HOUSES.
THEY ARE EITHER HELPING THEIR
FAMILY IN THEIR HOUSEHOLD CHORES
OR THEY ARE PUSHED INTO EARLY
CHILD MANAGERS OR THEY ARE
BECOMING THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORTERS OF THEIR FAMILY
BECAUSE OF THESE REASONS THERE
ARE MANY GIRLS WHO ARE NOT ABLE
TO CONTINUE THEIR STUDIES FROM
HOME AND THEY ARE NEVER ABLE TO
RETURN TO THEIR SCHOOLS.
SO, YOU KNOW, MY MISSION AND MY
HOPE IS THAT WE REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF THE MILLIONS OF GIRLS
WHO ARE OUT OF SCHOOL AND BRING
IT DOWN TO ZERO.
BUT RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE
COVID PANDEMIC, THERE IS THE
RISK THAT WE COULD SEE MORE
GIRLS BEING DEPRIVED OF THEIR
EDUCATION.
>> YEAH.
YOU WERE SAYING ABOUT 20 MILLION
GIRLS IN ADDITION TO THE 120
MILLION THAT ARE ALREADY OUT OF
SCHOOL AND BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC THEY ARE GOING THROUGH
JUST AWFUL THINGS WHETHER IT IS
JENNER BASED VIOLENCE, NOT BEING
ABLE TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES,
NOT BEING ABLE TO FEED THEIR
FAMILIES.
BUT IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE
MALALA THAT THESE PROBLEMS ARE
CERTAINLY VERY LAYERED AND VERY
NUANCED AND VERY COMPLEX.
SO WHAT WOMEN AND GIRLS ARE
GOING THROUGH IN MY HOME COUNTRY
NIGERIA IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WOMEN AND GIRLS ARE GOING
THROUGH IN YOUR HOME COUNTRY,
PAKISTAN.
WALK US THROUGH OF THE NUANCES
THE WORLD SHOULD BE AWARE OF.
>> VERY RIGHT.
THIS IS THE REALITY.
IT IS NOT -- UNFORTUNATELY AND
THAT IS THE APPROACH THAT --
ADOPTED TO WORK WITH LOCAL
EDUCATION ACTIVISTS.
AND WE ARE CURRENTLY WORKING IN
MORE THAN EIGHT COUNTRIES,
INCLUDING NIGEL REMARKS
PAKISTAN, INDIA, BRAZIL,
AFGHANISTAN.
BECAUSE THE REASONS WHY GIRL MAY
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO SCHOOL, THEY
DEPENDING ON THE REGION IT COULD
BE LACK OF FEMALE TEACHERS.
IT COULD BE LACK OF
TRANSPORTATIONS.
IT COULD BE THE LACK OF
GOVERNMENT-LEVEL POLICIES THAT
COULD PROVIDE GIRLS THE NEEDS
THAT MAKE SURE THEY ARE IN
SCHOOL FROM -- TO FEMALE
TEACHERS IN SCHOOL TO SAFETY IN
SCHOOL.
SO THERE ARE THREE GOALS THAT WE
FOCUS ON.
FIRST IS FINANCING FOR
EDUCATION.
UNFORTUNATELY FINANCING FOR
EDUCATION HAS BEEN STAGNANT.
AND ESPECIALLY IN COVID TIMES.
WORLD LEADERS HAVE BEEN
RELUCTANT TO SUPPORT GIRLS'
EDUCATION.
AND WE ARE SEEING A DECREASE IN
THEIR FUNDING.
SO IN THESE TIMES IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT WE PUSH THEM TO CONTINUE
SPENDING ON EDUCATION.
THEN THE SECOND IS CHALLENGING
SOCIAL NORMS BECAUSE THEY PLAY A
CRUCIAL ROLE IN THE RIGHTS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT GIRLS HAVE IN
A SOCIETY.
AND THEN THE THIRD ONE IS
QUALITY EDUCATION AND IN THAT
THERE ARE SOME KEY ELEMENTS THAT
WE SHOULD BE FOCUSES ON
INCLUDING PHYSICAL SAFETY, SEX
EDUCATION AND A LOT MORE TO
ENSURE THAT GIRLS AND ALL OF US
ARE RECEIVING THE EDUCATION, THE
QUALITY EDUCATION THAT WE NEED.
>> YEAH, I THINK ONE OF THE
BIGGEST ISSUES THAT YOU JUST
TOUCHED UPON IS CHANGING SOCIAL
NORMS.
BECAUSE THAT IS SO SO HARD
BECAUSE YOU ARE TALK ABOUT YEARS
OF CONDITIONING, GENERATIONS OF
KPING THAT IS VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TO UNDO.
I WANT TO HONE IN ON ONE COUNTRY
IN PARTICULAR, MY HOME COUNTRY
NIGERIA.
YOU SPENT TIME IN NIGERIA, AND I
SORT OF GET THE IMPRESSION THAT
NIGERIA IS A PLACE THAT IS VERY
VERY CLOSE TO YOUR HEART.
THE ISSUE OF GIRLS EDUCATION
NIGERIA CAME TO THE WORLD'S
ATTENTION OF COURSE IN 2014 WITH
THE MISSING GIRLS CAMPAIGN THE
BRING BACK OUR GIRLS CAMPAIGN.
BUT EVER SINCE THAT TIME IT'S
SORT OF FADED FROM VIEW A LITTLE
BIT.
YOU KNOW, DO YOU THINK IF THE
WORLD HAS BECOME DESENSITIZED TO
THE PLIGHT OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
PARTICULAR ANY IN NORTHERN NIENG
RA AND WHAT DO YOU THINK WE CAN
DO AS SOCIETY TO KEEP THE
WORLD'S ATTENTION ON THIS ISSUE?
>> YOU ARE VERY RIGHT.
SOMETIMES CERTAIN ISSUES GET
ATTENTION ON MEDIA AND THEN THEY
FADE AWAY BECAUSE IT IS NOT
TRENDING ANYMORE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE REALITIES
DON'T CHANGE.
ABDUCTIONS HAVE HAPPENED
REPEATEDLY.
IN NIGERIA AFTER THE ELECTION IN
2014.
AND IT HAS HAPPENED BEFORE AS
WELL.
ONE INCIDENT THAT GOT LOT OF
MEDIA ATTENTION AND IT SHOULD
GET IN ALL OF THOSE INCIDENTS
SHOULD GET THE ATTENTION BECAUSE
IT IS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF THESE
GIRLS.
WHEN THEY ARE IN SCHOOL THEY
SHOULD NOT BE WORRIED ABOUT SOME
TERRORIST GROUP ABDUCTING THEM.
THEY SHOULD BE THERE LEARNING,
READING, WRITING JUST AS ANY
STUDENT WOULD WANT TO DO.
SO IT IS UNIMAGINABLE TO THINK
ABOUT THE ATROCITIES THAT GIRLS
HAVE FACED THERE.
AND I WAS LUCKY THAT I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO NIGERIA
TWICE AND I ALSO MET THE GIRLS'
PARENTS WHO WERE ABDUCTED BY
BOKO HARAM.
AND JUST THE PAIN THAT I SAW IN
THEIR EYES AND IN THEIR HEARTS
WAS UNIMAGINABLE.
THEIR ATROCITIES THEY HAVE BEEN
THROUGH.
THE DIFFICULTIES THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN THROUGH AND SINCE THEN WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING IN NIGERIA,
WORKING WITH LOCAL ACTIVISTS
THERE ARE WHO ARE FIGHTING FOR
GIRLS' EDUCATION WHO ARE
CHALLENGING THE -- GIRLS ARE
FACING PUSHING FOR STATE LEVEL
POLICY CHANGES TO ENSURE SAFE
AND QUALITY EDUCATION.
>> AND JUST IN TERMS OF YOUR
IMPRESSIONS OF NIGERIA.
LISTEN, IT WAS A DIRE SITUATION
BACK THEN FOR WOMEN AND GIRLS,
THAT THE VIOLENCE AND THE
INSECURITY IN NIGERIA HAS ONLY
INCREASED SINCE THEN.
IT IS A TOUGH COUNTRY TO HOLD
TOGETHER EVEN IN THE BEST OF
TIMES.
WERE YOU HOPEFUL WHEN YOU LEFT
NIGERIA?
>> A BIT OF ATTENTION WAS
BROUGHT TO THE ISSUE.
THE EDUCATION MINISTRY HAD BEEN
WORKING THERE.
SO THERE HAS BEEN BIT OF
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUE.
AND ALSO SOME OF THE GIRLS WERE
RELEASED FROM ABDUCTION.
AND I KNOW IT IS A CHALLENGING
PLACE.
AND BUT THAT IS TRUE ABOUT SO
MANY OTHER COUNTRIES AS WELL.
AND THAT SHOULD NOT STOP US FROM
WORKING FOR EDUCATION.
I THINK IT IS OFTEN TIME THESE
EXCUSES THAT WE USE SAYING THAT,
YOU KNOW, THERE IS A LOT OF
TERRORISM, EXTREMISM, THIS
COUNTRY IS NOT SAFE SO WE
SHOULDN'T WORK THERE.
AND THINGS REMAIN AS THEY ARE.
THINGS OFTEN WORSEN.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE DO
WHAT IS IN OUR CAPACITY AND MAKE
SURE WE CONTRIBUTE TOWAR